[inaudible].
Okay.
Before we get started with today's
video,
I've got to give you two warnings.
The first is that we might include some
spoilers about narcos on via sleep or
given that it's a TV show based on real
history,
I don't think this is so much of a
problem and the second warning is that
today we're going to talk about drug
trafficking,
a topic where the information we have is
pretty incomplete and all the time
police to finding new bits of
information that could prove parts of
this video wrong.
Tell you.
That being said,
let's move on to Colombia.
The country that is known of the country
of a thousand rhythms,
the country of coffee and the birthplace
of so many of those Latino singers that
got the whole world to dance.
Nevertheless,
what really made this country famous is
sadly this man [inaudible] video
[inaudible] the king of cocaine,
the man who basically created one of the
world's most dangerous industries at the
ends of the 1980s Pablo Escobar or El
Patron,
as his neighbors used to know him,
controlled it,
and 90% of the worldwide production of
cocaine.
Suddenly it met a Yin and a city of 2
million inhabitants became the Hollywood
of cocaine.
However,
on December the first 1993 he died
during a shootout with the police.
But well,
you've probably already knew that.
So the question now becomes,
well,
what happens after Pablo who took his
business?
Ma'Ams then there is the most important
question of all,
and that is,
is there still cocaine trafficking in
Columbia?
Well,
today we're certainly going to answer
all of those questions,
but before we get into any of that,
let's talk a little bit about cocaine.
Yeah,
weed.
Cocaine is the second most consumed drug
in the world,
but it's unlike the first one that
cocaine is extremely hard to find
marijuana.
It groves anywhere on the planet,
even in cold places like North America
grow houses are found all the time.
And with just a little bit of
expenditure,
anyone can create at home the optimal
conditions for growing cannabis.
That's coca leaves.
They are a different animal.
You need a very specific habitat to grow
them.
And this is why only some countries can
grow these leaves,
but the main countries are Colombia.
Peru and Bolivia ship.
Cool.
Okay.
In other words,
there is just space for a few suppliers,
but on the other hand,
the demand,
it won't stop growing as well.
It's a gullible demands.
This is why it cocaine is such a high
profit business,
and this is why right after Pablo
Escobar's death,
there were lots of people willing to
take his place.
[inaudible] feel
bores.
As you know,
probably West Guevara was the leader of
the median cartel,
but even before his death,
there was already a second cocaine
capital,
and that was the city of Cali,
also in Columbia and with a very similar
population.
We're Pablo left a trail of bodies and
chaos.
Since week Kelly May problems disappear
with an army of lawyers and a mountain
of legal briefs.
Met Him.
Cartel was Miami,
swimming pools,
bikini girls.
Taki is a two tone cadillac.
The Cali cartel was New York,
elegant,
smooth,
subtle,
where they can fuel the 24 hour night,
live with cocaine and still make sure
everybody showed up for work on Wall
Street.
The next morning,
the first met Ian and Kelly works side
by side,
but in Colombia when money's involved,
blood inevitably flows.
The Cali cartel,
they wanted to take the whole of
Escobar's business that many in plenty
of Narcos who wants to do the same
thing.
One of them with Diego Fernandez,
Marillo Aka dawn.
Bye now.
It helps the police deal with Pablo
Escobar and made an alliance with the
Cali cartel.
I'd even had close ties with a right
wing paramilitary group called the
Colombian self defense forces with Pablo
Escobar dead and buried.
Don dunner started a new organization
with this paramilitary group,
the so called office center,
Dan Vergano.
At the same time,
smaller narcos in metagene.
We're also fighting for their share.
The street you see on the screen was the
border between one band.
Yeah.
Basically,
if you were a worker for the ovc now the
end de Gallo and cross the street,
someone would kill you immediately.
So as you can imagine that these were
extremely violent times for the city,
different drug bands,
or killing each other pretty much all
the time.
Meanwhile,
the Cali cartel was way more subtle.
This is Gilberto Rodriguez and his
partner,
Pasho Herrera.
They were high class buyers with plenty
of contact,
some on politicians and judges.
In fact,
Gilberto Rodriguez paid over $6 million
to finance the campaign of one of the
Colombian presidents anesto Santa's
nonetheless,
despite beautifully when it's in the
corruption after sometime the inevitable
happens.
Yes,
Sonia,
I'll go.
We are not.
Government has started the extradition
process for the chief of the Cali
cartel.
Nonetheless,
dawn burner volunteers.
He was at a totally different story
among all the characters that appear on
the Narcos TV show.
Dawn burner is the one who has lost the
longest without being put behind bars,
but we're just a minute because now we
can talk about in the characters that
didn't appear on the show at least in
the first two seasons,
and to prepare yourself because,
well,
there's a lot to tell.
Remember how don burner was working with
this right wing group?
Well,
the political ideology was more
important than what you might think for
this group.
The Colombian self defense forces.
They were born to fight against
communist guerrillas in the country.
Collusionary
armed forces of Colombia,
Fark Fark.
It's more than just a simple terrorist
group.
In some areas of the country,
they became a parallel government more
than an Alpha eater kind of thing.
They could be better comparison with
dash or Islamic state.
Even today,
a good parts of the Colombian rainforest
is under the control of this Marxist
Leninist group.
Fox,
they had their own doctors,
their own hospitals,
and of course they collected their own
taxes.
This group has over 20,000
members spread across 24 of Columbia's
32 provinces.
As you can imagine,
Fox,
they were not good friends of drug
trafficking.
Yes,
drug traffic isn't terrorists.
They do have common enemies,
but the idea of becoming a millionaire
by selling a product on the
international market doesn't sound very
Marxist.
Besides extortion and kidnapping,
they were pretty lucrative businesses as
well as FARC.
They were experts on these matters.
Add to this,
the fact that don burner and this office
seen to and vanguard who had an
anticommunist group on their site,
and you can imagine that the war,
it was about to happen,
but with this
is the boy,
Huh?
Municipality.
I data today,
it's covered by plants and trees.
That is the north,
apart from where bark launched rockets
to the other part of the municipality,
but well,
business is business and the mass of the
money for could make with kidnapping.
It was hard to resist the temptation of
drug trafficking.
So one day Mudita [inaudible] has one of
the main thought leaders decided to try
in the cocaine business.
Yes.
Jean Front of the FARC went from 200
members to over 800 due to cocaine
revenue,
which became one of the primary ways the
Koreas finance their activities.
Don't forget the FARC have the control
of all the areas where coca plantations,
where in fact they had already extorted
the growers.
Nonetheless with Medina,
Caracas is leader.
FARC have created their own fields and
their own distribution networks.
This was all happening by the year 2000
at this time,
the Cali cartel,
it was already dismantled,
but cocaine,
it was still employing a good share of
the Colombian workforce.
Well,
to summarize,
on the one hand,
we have the office sooner to envision
Gado with don burner as the leader and
then we have FARC on the other hands and
between these two there's also a
plethora of independent drug trafficking
bands called the backroom.
It was during this time the Columbia
chosen you president's Alvara rebate.
Early Bay was born in Midian and this
political goal was to end all the
violence am's.
Well,
this marks the beginning of the tox
mafioso oh Volvo or rebate.
Was it ready to end the guerrilla
warriors and the right wing groups at
any cost.
This is why in the year 2005 is Defense
Minister Camilo or Spina signed the law
that is thought of with sadness in
Colombia.
This law was directive zero to nine and
as well.
Now you might be wondering,
well,
what's so sad about that?
It sounds like it could be a good thing.
This directive said literally that the
government would give the equivalent of
1900 US dollars to anyone who would
murder a guerrilla fighter or a
paramilitary,
right wing fighter.
Sure.
Basically,
if you were a soldier in the Colombian
army ends,
you wanted to have a good career.
All you had to do was get out and go on
a man Hans,
and all of a sudden,
well,
the death toll at Fark Ama narcos,
it absolutely skyrocketed,
but hold on a minute because this was
just the beginning.
Finding FARC members,
it wasn't an easy job,
but the rewards given by the Colombian
government was really,
really tempting.
This is why a lots of soldiers started
killing innocent civilians.
After that,
they would dress the metaphoric uniform
and take a picture of the dad's body.
This was enough to go to the government
office and gets the money and this is
something that happens way more than
once or twice.
There is even a name for it.
In Colombia,
the dad civilians were called false
positives and it became a major way for
people to make money in Colombia.
It's still today,
the Colombian justice system has over
3000 ongoing cases of false positives
that need to be investigated.
But wait a minute,
because while the policies of presidents
or rebate,
we're extremely controversial,
one thing has to be set.
He made it way more complicated for FARC
guerrilla warriors,
raids on cocaine fields and distribution
networks.
They became the norm.
And when your enemy is killing dozens of
your members,
you are willing to sign an alliance with
the devil himself.
Some emails prove the links between the
FARC and the narco traffickers and one
of the messages and Middle Kaneko Oh
Korea leader shows a clear connection
with the OPC and the end of the Godell.
As we said before,
fuck would present at all the
plantations.
In some cases,
those plantations,
they belonged to the office scene to end
Gatto or some belongs to the back room
that we mentioned earlier.
On the other hand,
sometimes patients were managed directly
by fog.
These aren't where they grew and
processed cocoa leaves and turns them
into white powder.
Then the big cartels steps into
distributes the cocaine to other
countries.
Nonetheless,
unlike the times of Pablo Escobar,
Colombian cartels and no longer have a
monopoly over distribution.
For instance,
when those Columbia narcos want to send
[inaudible] to the u s they partner with
Mexican drug dealers when they want to
send it to Europe.
They work with Italian,
Greek and Albanian mafias,
but we're going to talk about all of
that in another video and not today.
The important thing is,
despite drug trafficking still being an
issue today,
metagene is now a peaceful city.
Of course,
there are still bad neighborhoods where
it's better not to walk through,
especially on the outskirts of the city,
but the city has made a big change
change for the better.
This pax mafioso has allowed all the
players involved with the cocaine
business to make an agreement so that
each of them has their territories and
they have no reason to kill each other.
Yes,
cocaine is now easier to find than ever.
There's less people die during the
process.
Awesome.
Now,
you might be wondering,
well,
what can happen that FARC have made a
peace agreements with the Colombian
government?
Well,
this could become an opportunity for the
background to take back control of the
business that is now in the qubit as
Hams,
but the truth is these Nike's,
they're also trying to get a peace
agreement with the government that is
just as profitable as the one that
fucking and negotiating crazy as it
sounds for claims to be a political
group with their ideology and propaganda
even available on their website,
which can be visited by anyone.
This is
why they sit on equal terms with the
government.
However,
backroom are seen as normal criminals
with no politics or ideology whatsoever.
Ads,
of course,
well days norcos they're thinking,
hey,
why can fox or with the governments and
why can't we?
The agreements between the FARC and the
government,
they're extremely good for the gorillas
and once again,
everyone,
they want a piece of it.
Hey,
well that's a whole other story as well
and now it's your turn.
Do you think it's possible to end the
trafficking of cocaine or do you think
it's simply a matter that each time one
band is dismantled and other ones simply
appears?
Well,
please do leave your answers in the
comments section below.
You should also definitely visit the
reconsider media podcasts that they
provided,
the voices on this video that are not
mine.
And don't forget that we published brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday.
So don't forget to subscribe.
Hit that button below me now and you
won't miss any post.
Also,
if you did like this video,
do give us a thumbs up and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
don't forget to check out the
reconsidered podcast@reconsidermedia.com
reconsidered as a podcast that
challenges you to reconsider your views
by providing context,
but we don't do the thinking for you.